go one and a half miles
in 2013 anton simon was crisscrossing
oklahoma roads in a minivan
anton is a scientist who studies
tornadoes and his team saw
a huge one out the window wait okay yeah
keep going it's very close tornado very
close
and we began driving south and i thought
we were in a very safe position and then
things began to deteriorate in a way
that i was not familiar with
all of a sudden the tornado changed
directions
it also ballooned to a much bigger size
before he knew it anton was way too
close
the wind began to get very intense
roaring at us as a headwind from the
south
probably blowing at least 100 miles an
hour and
as these things happen we're basically
engulfed by this giant circulation of
the tornado
wow you know a four-cylinder minivan
doesn't do very well in a hundred mile
an hour headwind but
less that dodge caravan it got us out of
there
all right we're probably out of danger
but keep going
that's going nice going
after anton made it to safety all he
could see
was a gigantic wall of rain
in decades of storm chasing he had never
seen a tornado like this
it was too large to be a tornado in my
head i was trying to
understand what i was looking at but
tornadoes are not this large you know
this is 10 times larger than a large
tornado
so you know how does one get to get
one's head around what's going on it
was really really strange and weird it
wasn't just anton
he was staring at a tornado that
measured more than two and a half miles
wide
the largest ever recorded and then
he thought of something else i said this
is the first storm that's going to kill
storm chasers and i had no doubt about
it
it was terrible you know it was a
horrible feeling
anton would find out the tornado hit
even closer to home than he imagined
he couldn't bring back the people he
lost but maybe
studying the tornado and learning
lessons for the future
could help him find some kind of meaning
[Music]
i'm peter gwynne and this is overheard
at national geographic a show where we
eavesdrop on the wild conversations we
have here at natgeo
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
this week the quest to go inside the
most
violent storms on earth and how a new
way of studying tornadoes
could teach us to detect them earlier
and hopefully save lives
[Music]
i've always thought of tornadoes as
scary monsters
you know the kind of thing you see in
the wizard of oz a black hole that
reaches down from the sky and snatches
innocent people out of their beds
but that's not how anton simon sees them
anton says
it all starts with a type of
thunderstorm called a supercell
where you get a supercell thunderstorm
you have the potential for
a significant tornado supercell
thunderstorms are breathtaking to behold
they're
giant sky sculptures they're
extraordinary beasts and anton has
chased those beasts
for almost 30 years he's a national
geographic
explorer and every year he logs
thousands of miles
driving around the great plains from
texas to canada
and from the rockies all the way to
indiana tell me about
the life of a storm chaser what is that
life like
yes storm chasing lifestyle is not a
very healthy thing
uh typically involves very bad food
sometimes uncomfortable accommodations
ridiculous
numbers of hours just sitting in the
driver's seat of a car or the passenger
seat
um waiting for something to happen uh
it's certainly not glamorous
but seeing a storm unfold is worth the
wait
anton says he's not looking for
adrenaline or thrills
just the most promising thunderclouds
and when he finds them
the chase is on the analogy i draw
is you're playing chess with the
atmosphere
and sometimes the clouds never develop
you know the
the difference in atmospheric conditions
that can produce just a sunny afternoon
or a maximum intensity tornado can be
the difference can be infinitesimally
small and impossible to discern
beforehand
even for experts like anton it's a
mystery why some
supercells create massive tornadoes
and others just fizzle out tornadoes
have killed more than 900 people in the
united states since 2010
and understanding them is the first step
to saving lives
why is it necessary for a person even a
scientist to get anywhere near a tornado
isn't that like what radar sort of isn't
technology sort of taken
the human element out of this what the
radar beam
does you know a radar sense sends a
signal out it bounces back off
particles objects cloud droplets dust
and whatever
is out there and bounces back to the
radar gives information
that works great at cloud level but
anton says there's one place where
things get
tricky at ground level trees and
buildings get in the way of radar beams
that's all the structures are and that's
where all the human mortality occurs
is right at the surface so the very
place that
you would want a radar beam to be giving
you the maximum information is that one
place that a radar beam can't actually
see
so to understand what's happening at
ground level you have to figure out
another way to see
inside a tornado and that's not easy
it's weird to think that you know
towards the end of the 20th century
we had no data at ground level from
inside the core of a violent tornado
this is brantley hargrove he's a
journalist and he says
for a long time we were missing really
basic information
like how fast is the wind at ground
level is it warm inside a tornado or
cool according to brantley scientists
could only guess
structural engineers obviously need to
know these things because they need to
know
you know how strong do we need to build
this this hospital
how strong do we need to build this
school um and
you know they were just guesses before
this they were just
you know sort of blank spaces in the
equation that nobody had filled in yet
brantley wrote a biography of tim
samaras a self-taught
engineer obsessed with filling in those
blanks
in the early 2000s tim teamed up with
anton simon
and tim built a two foot wide probe
painted bright orange
it looked like an alien turtle he
designed the probe to lay flat on the
ground
as a tornado passed over it and measure
things like
wind speed and atmospheric pressure tim
and anton would track a tornado in their
car
and then brantley says can we grab his
probe and pounce
so walk me through how you how you put
one of those out like how would
tim deploy one of these so you've got to
figure out
where this tornado is going to be maybe
a minute from now or two minutes from
now really as little as possible
uh to narrow the margin of air then you
hop
out you grab that probe uh uh activate
it there's a little switch on the bottom
uh you lay it on the ground maybe kind
of off to the side of the road
um and then you hightail it out of there
depending on how
how close the tornado is
oh my god you got a wedge on the ground
wedge on the ground wipers please
this is video taken in 2003 anton and
tim are driving around the texas
panhandle
they pull over and not far in the
distance
a tornado is heading straight toward
them
oh my god that was it oh tim you got to
get out the car and just be careful
tim was just so remarkably cool under
the pressure there um
in that particular instant we were
sitting alongside him
i mean we both were you know we're
really focused on the task at hand
uh and and the safety element and then
baseball size health starts falling down
and banging on the roof and starting to
smash all the windows
you've got baseballs falling tim these
will take your head off man
just hang the thing out as anton holds a
camcorder in the passenger seat
tim drops the probe by the side of the
road and scrambles back to the car
then tim floors it down the highway
you might actually slow down a bit no
okay
i don't want to get broadsided no it's
just rfd wrapping around
oh my god slow down slow down
100 power line down power left side turn
the power post to come down here
power poles are bending i've never seen
that in my life they're bending
towel balance down slow down slow down
with a 100 mile an hour
winds knocking power lines right into
their path
tim drives to safety anton says
just a minute and a half after they fled
the tornado barreled through the exact
spot where they pulled over
when you deliberately cross into that
zone where you're getting into that
you know uh the path of where the
tornado you know is going to track and
destroy things
it's very strange indeed and i you know
yeah on one hand you know every instinct
your body's telling you to panic and get
the heck out of there on the other hand
this the scientist
is just so fascinated by what i'm
witnessing you know in that video at one
point tim says we're gonna die
and you know once you make it out he
says you know that was too close
i mean did you feel like that like you
had sort of crossed a
line there no i i you hear me sort of
trying to reassure him i i i didn't feel
it was
nearly as desperate as he was
communicating but yeah
it is very intense and um you know it
was for after that
particular experience i
evaluated things and decided that i
should
probably stop trying to deploy probes
into tornadoes because if i persisted at
that
at some point my luck would run out
things would catch up with me
after that anton stopped chasing
tornadoes with tim
the research was too dangerous and he
wanted to chase on his own terms
just one month after the narrow escape
in texas
tim hit it big he played matador again
this time with a tornado in south dakota
journalist brantley hargrove says
tim positioned his probe perfectly it
hadn't moved an inch
even though a incredibly violent tornado
had passed over it
not only did it survive he knew it was
gathering data
for you know tornado researchers and
storm chasers this was like the
excalibur moment i mean this was like
you know i've done it
for the first time ever tim had
collected real
concrete information about the center of
a tornado the data was revolutionary for
understanding
what happens inside a tornado and it
wasn't just
researchers paying attention tim samaras
became the face of storm chasing
he was featured in a national geographic
cover story
and he also starred in a tv show tim's
aggressive storm chasing was valuable to
scientists
and to hit with the public the only way
tim was able to get these measurements
is because he was willing to push it a
little bit and so
you know you push it long enough and
eventually you know it will
it will bite you
in 2013 a decade after they had last
worked together
tim samaras and anton simon separately
followed the same storm to oklahoma
hundreds of other storm chasers were
there too anton says the brewing storm
put a bull's-eye right on top of
oklahoma city
so that really freaked me out because um
you know more than a million people are
living in that area in harm's way
also you know i've got family members in
the
city area and you know had breakfast
with my
mother-in-law that morning um at a diner
and she said so how's today looking you
know
and i just implored i said it looks
terrifying i said
if when those sirens go off later today
get in your basement please just really
this is a bad
this is a really serious setup all right
so we are
we're in the edge of the circulation but
this is the storm that boggled anton's
mind the one that seemed
too large to even be a tornado
as it grew stronger the tornado became
more erratic
it chewed through buildings near a small
town called el reno
and it crossed over roads jammed with
stormchasers cars
all right that redeveloped very close in
on us people
all right nice toy
so a bunch of chasers were hit by that
no doubt anyone behind us would have
been hit
i freely admit i was clueless as to what
was going on
i knew it was strange i knew that we had
to put some distance in there
i thought we were playing it safe and we
were still caught wow so then what about
all those people who are actually
you know trying to be much bolder trying
to get closer in
after the skies cleared storm chasers
checked in with each other
almost everyone was accounted for but
the next day
no one had heard from tim samaras and
sometime
after midnight i woke up and i checked
the social media again and then
for the first time i saw a note saying
i hope this rumor is not true but i was
like oh god
the rumor was that tim samaras had died
in the tornado
and it was true the tornado killed eight
people
including tim and his son paul and
another chase partner named carl young
according to journalist brantley
hargrove the storm changed so quickly
that it caught tim off guard
you know it's always struck me how
unlikely
um what happened really was
you know so many things had to go wrong
an exact sequence if they had been
20 seconds ahead
on the road or 20 seconds behind i think
they probably would have survived
um but they just happened to be in the
exact wrong place at the exact wrong
time
anton simon and other veteran storm
chasers
were shocked it was just you know
so heartbreaking and so so sad
and there was this you know gigantic
freak out because
there had been no there'd never been a
storm chaser killed while storm chasing
as far as we knew
and so there's a lot of soul searching
is how did this happen well you know
what went wrong
you know you know was it the actions of
the chases themselves was the storm
really that unusual
and in this
mystery were the seeds of a major
research
case to understand why the el reno
tornado killed his friends
anton needed to study the storm and
there was a lot to unpack
the tornado was more than two and a half
miles wide
the largest ever recorded its wind
speeds of 300 miles an hour
were some of the strongest in weather
history and it created some of the
biggest hail recorded anywhere
about the size of volleyballs it had
this extraordinary
phenomenon that said okay you know this
is obviously a case worth studying
but there there's this whole other angle
that kind of as as a storm chasing
researcher myself i felt like i really
wanted to
study the storm to try to understand
what the heck happened here
since the 1990s an idea had been rolling
around anton's brain
maybe he could use video to analyze a
tornado at ground level
with so many storm chasers on hand there
must be plenty of video to work with
i came up with a list of 250
individual chasers or chaser groups who
were in the vicinity of el reno on that
afternoon which is
kind of amazing yeah you know i yeah and
i had no idea how
international storm chasing had become
it turns out there were 30 storm chasers
from
australia that come out from australia
to chase american storms
oh my god they were all out there
surrounding the storm so things like
that were
quite amazing anton ended up with dozens
of videos
a kind of mosaic showing the tornado
from all different points of view
gathering the material is just the first
step you have to then turn it into
scientific data
now you know somebody's home movie is
not instantly scientific data you have
to do all sorts of processing to
actually make it worthwhile
this was tedious work first anton needed
to know exactly where each video was
shot
down to a few feet that's not made easy
through things like google maps and
google earth
you can simulate scenes and now compare
what you see on the video to
to find the perfect match even a vehicle
driving 60 miles an hour down a road
we know where that camera was next he
needed to know
when the videos were happening for this
anton relied on something that showed up
in
every video lightning when their major
lightning flash is recorded on video we
can actually go to the archive of
lightning flashes from the storm
we know the exact time of those
lightning flashes and we can
put together the timeline of all those
video clips that we have
finally anton was ready to share his
data with the world
he says his videos told the story of the
el reno tornado in a whole new way
we are able to map out the storm in a
manner that had never been done before
we have
now an archive of imagery
of a single storm over a one hour period
as it goes
through the cycle of producing this
gigantic tornado and all these other
phenomena
you can see it from multiple
perspectives and
really understand things how they work
when scientists
dug into those videos they made a huge
discovery
anton published a scientific paper with
a timeline of how the tornado formed
and his paper grabbed the attention of
another scientist named janna hauser
we collect data through a mobile radar
which in our case basically looks like
a big cone-shaped dish on top of a
relatively large flatbed pickup truck
jana is a meteorologist at ohio
university
she had also studied the el reno tornado
and at first
she focused on what happened in the
clouds
janna worked on a scientific paper that
also detailed
when the tornado formed but something
was off
there was actually a two-minute
disconnect between
their time and our time with their time
being earlier
than what we had seen in the radar data
two minutes
it might not seem like much but to janna
this was a major head scratcher
why did the tornado show up in anton's
videos before
her radar saw it in the sky she took a
closer look at the data
basically you were witnessing the birth
of this
particular tornado is that what's going
on yes
that is exactly what is going on and
what we
observed with our eyes that that's what
anton's group did
and then what we saw with the
radar analysis was that this tornado
very clearly
started at or very close to the ground
and then suddenly expanded upwards
so picture the first moments of a
tornado
maybe you imagine a scary looking cloud
that starts to rotate
and then a long black tentacle reaches
down from the sky
even though tornadoes look like that
janna and anton realized the el reno
tornado didn't actually happen that way
the tornado formed first at ground level
and then it spun up into the clouds
nobody had ever recorded this happening
from a scientific perspective it's
almost like the missing link
you know so we have had this theory
we've been able to show this in models
but there
has been essentially no or very limited
observational
evidence to support this and it wasn't
just the el reno tornado
janna discovered that other tornadoes
formed the very same way
it seems like most tornadoes develop on
the ground first
and she says this new information shows
a major hole in the way we predict
tornadoes
it all goes back to radar forecasters
can
see what's happening at cloud level but
on the ground
we can't actually observe this low-level
rotation
in 99 of the cases
at least using the technology that's
available to
the weather forecasters at the national
weather service or
even at your local news newsroom
so by the time forecasters detect a
tornado
and warn people what's coming the storm
could be a few critical minutes ahead
anton simon says it might be time to
rethink how we monitor thunderstorms
maybe part of the problem is we've been
we have an over-reliance
on technologies which are tracking
what's going on
in that cloud level and not enough uh
focus on what's going on closer to the
ground which of course
you know what our findings are are
showing
is really where the tornado itself will
spin up
anton wants to fix that he plans to keep
building on the work of tim samaras to
find out what's
actually going on inside tornadoes and
maybe his discoveries could even help
protect people in the future
you know i'd do anything in my power to
get my friends back
but given all that has transpired i feel
like we've derived great meaning and
great value
from this awful experience um
and you know all these subsequent
efforts to understand the storm and to
for the story to be told as accurately
as possible
um they're teaching us many things anton
thinks video data
could solve even more tornado mysteries
and his team has become more
sophisticated now they strategically fan
out around the tornado and record
videos from several angles plus new
video technology means their data is
getting better and better all the time
4k video is a treasure trove for us
because
it is so it's a sufficiently high
resolution that we can really see a lot
of the fan scale detail
the smaller particles in motion little
patches of dust
being whipping around a tornado leaves
in motion things like that
that really we couldn't see and what we
used to consider to be high definition
video
so that's been quite a breakthrough as
anton
closes in on 30 years of tornado
research
he still sees a lot of storm chasing in
his future
even during the kobit 19 pandemic
anton's team found a way to chase safely
we did some unusual things we bought 10
days of food with us and so we never
actually had to sit down in a restaurant
anywhere
you know actions like that uh really
helped
but the key was always being vigilant
never forgetting that this is an unusual
situation
what is it that pulls you out every
spring i mean like you said you
it sounds like you've seen it kind of
all you know from el reno
on down one of the most compelling
things
is that you said you must have seen it
all
is we absolutely know we haven't seen it
all and that
draws us back every year because there's
always something you know
every year brings some new experiences
and if i didn't have a research interest
in the world i'd still be out there
every day i could when big storms start
thundering across the great plains in
the spring anton will be there
and his video camera will be rolling
more after the break
[Music]
there's something about tornadoes that's
completely mesmerizing
you just can't look away and you can see
that for yourself in our show notes
we have links to some of anton's tornado
videos
you can also find out more about tornado
science we have cool graphics and videos
that explain how tornadoes form and some
helpful tips to stay safe
there's even a list of emergency
supplies to stock up on just in case
and for subscribers you can read a
national geographic magazine article
called the last chase it details why tim
samaras pushed himself
to become one of the world's most
successful tornado researchers
and how the el reno tornado became the
first to kill storm chasers
that's in the show notes right there in
your podcast app
overheard at national geographic is
produced by jacob pinter
ryan gutierrez and laura sim our senior
editor is eli
chen executive producer of audio is
davar artelon
who also edited this episode our fact
checker is michelle harris
hansdale sue composed our theme music
and engineers our episodes
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host peter gwynne see y'all
next time
[Music]
you